シーズ母にズボッとに帰ってきましたこちらのヤマケン僕の実家などでございます半年
ぶりにちょっとゆっくり実家で出来る時間がなんとか出来ました少しなんですけども
しばらくテーマでいるそうなんでと言いたいところなんですけども今日はですけど一つ
やってみたいことがありましてこちらの馬いるバッテリー
使ったことありますでしょうか父ちゃんも母ちゃんの寝てるからさ4月
による値上げてみましょうツボトートも出てるよ
結果だとねそのみんな寝てるからさあ静かに行っていたためだ
こんな感じでございますコースと充電ができるとこちらに挿す場所がございますここ
からモバイルバッテリ自身を充電できて
を指すとこの先から色々ねスマホとか pocket wifi とかに充電できると
言う
ものでございます大鈴は考えたそこのモバイルバッテリた普通に充電できるわけじゃで
もこれだけだとされた充電できる限界があるわけですそこで私は
4日
子連れにたくさんのモバイルバッテリ済みしましたこれは思ってこれを持ってしまった
ことモバイルバッテリーで僕の兄もうずう連しますこれは分かりませんモバイル
バッテリーで僕の iphone を充填しますでこの充電してるモバイルバッテリー
をお花がモバイルバッテリーで充電しますこうこうこういう感じですスマートフォンを
このモバイルバッテリーで充電しますがこんなモバイルバッテリー旅行
モバイルバッテリーで充電もうこれはね我ながらに天才だと思ったこの後 by 待っ
てるよ子供がいる張っていて充填してさらにこのモバイルバッテリー他のモバイル
バッテリーで充電するとして阿蘇他の充電してモバイルバッテリーさらに他のモバイル
バッテリーで充電する仕事もは威張ってるされ他のモバイルバッテリーで充電する人し
それにこのもらえればっているために他のこと
お前を待ってる繋げてるだけで無限にスマートフォンが
運転できるんじゃねーか買ってきたモバイルバッテリ全部開けますねっ
こいつらをつなげましょう max 2ですか一応で max にはなってるんですよ
まーすって来たら3時間がないなのかな一個2時間だと計算するとあっちがあるので
ずう6時間です僕の iphone が残り充電が17%増16時間+これが100%
になるとすると24時間かな24時間を持つと思います間違いない今から電気
つけっぱにしますから電源つけっぱなしにして24時間持つとかさに良い方だと思うの
でモバイルバッテリーでモバイルバッテリーを充電し合ってスマートフォンは何時間
持つのかと検証していこうと思います
俺は実家に来て何やってんだか僕は友達なら
みんなで充電し合おう
幸せいっぱいならピンクのバッテリーをあなたが2ですそのあなたをあなたが充電する
でそんなあなたをあんた中です回どうでしょうかこいつら全部光ってるのがやる気は
あるみたいです
10年かなり少ないんですけどもまぁ僕が
起きる頃には max になっており鼻にまだ全然動いてるイメージだと思います
ちょっと全部付いてるからね
を供給では僕は今から寝るんですけども32000 ma の後ガールパっていいです
よ
ビビるぽパターン332000 ma の覚えるパってるパックに僕のその後戻るだけ
物ので食ってポカねますへと電源は落ちないようにしてあるので常に電力が消費され
ます用意したとはい始まりました
ただ全部付いてるからね ok the おやすみなさい
バッハ
うん
ああああああ
ん
次の日の朝
信じられない光景が目の前にあっ
バンブー
ぶー& a
バンドれ
あんなにも壊れバッテリ接続して太郎ねー
car
うん
ua
ua ぜ
ごめんなさい
war
しています